there's there seems to be there's this
trend of you know women in their 40s and
even older who are dating younger dudes
you kind of touched on it that these
guys are approaching more what have you
so Kim Kardashian uh 41 years old dates
Pete Davidson now
a [ __ ] boy some people may say 28 years
old Britney Spears just got married if I
don't know if you heard about that she's
40. she married a 28 year old okay and
then you got Madge Madonna out there 63
years old coming out and publicly saying
I will not date a guy older than 30.
she's just banging 20 something year old
guys out there Galore okay so yeah I
love it what is happening right here the
these young not as you know they're not
the Breadwinners the women are the
Breadwinners walk us through the mindset
of why these women want these younger
men not not often the Breadwinners
sometimes they are but not often you're
correct I'll tell you what's happening
there's a lot of women right now that
are keep in shape where I'm very I'm
gonna use myself an example I don't know
what Kim Kardashians were like very
energetic exercise workout take care of
my body I got like energy I'm like the
Energizer Bunny all the time and a lot
of men have let themselves go there's a
lot of older men that have just let
themselves grow they don't exercise they
got the belly the big fat belly they're
lazy they're sitting on the couch
they're unmotivated they're like it's
almost like they're like 10 years deep
into a marriage only they're not married
they're just sitting around they're not
motivated and a lot of these younger men
they're motivated they're ambitious
they're energetic they're at the gym
they're like hey let's do this let's do
that they're making the most of life
that's very sexy and that's very very
appealing so I wasn't looking for a
younger man like I said this is the
first younger man I've ever dated it's
not a pattern for me in fact it's quite
the opposite but what I was attracted to
was his spark and energy for life and
there's a lot of very passionate very
capable very energetic women out there
that aren't finding a compatible man in
their age bracket so they're just
grabbing contorting toward that
gravitating toward that energy and
that's common in the form of a younger
man and so do you think this is going to
become more prevalent as women start to
make more money be able to you know the
more money you make the more you can
afford a personal trainer the more you
can afford maybe to get some work done
whatever you're doing your thing and if
men their age group or even older are
letting themselves go fat bald you know
unattractive what have you they're like
[ __ ] it I'm gonna bang the 20s that's
why I'm telling you it's not just about
money like a guy a guy who has money
though I'm saying a guy who has money
that's great you know you Financial
stability is a positive thing that mean
you are you were ambitious in life you
went for something you achieved it
that's admirable but you could be a rich
guy sitting at home with a beer guts
sitting on watching Netflix or playing
whatever do you're not attractive you're
not attractive I will take a younger
ambitious motivated man who doesn't have
as much in the bank at all but is is
living life and who wants to go out and
do things and hey let's take the kid
here and let's I will take that any day
lesson with the prenup okay fellas out
there your comfort zone will kill you do
not get too comfortable in your marriage
is what I'm hearing you're 40 years old
you've been married for 10 years you've
got a couple kids I'm married I make all
the money where's she going buddy we
just learned 10 years younger that's
where she goes
you talked about women getting the
furniture you said oh women getting
surgery and you always talk about women
like maintaining their beauty because
there is a separate societal standard
for appearances when it comes to women
there's an expectation on women that men
I remember sitting on TV sets and
everybody was worried about my hair and
makeup and there was a fat ball guy next
to me I was like you're not worried
about what he looks like what are they
going to do happens all the time so put
that on there put that on men and say
you know what guys you want your woman
to be happy you got to take care of your
[ __ ] too it's not just on us I'm not I
mean I'm not gonna yeah I gotta dye my
hair I gotta do this what about you you
got that beer gut hanging out not you
not you but are you talking about Roger
Ailes that [ __ ] happens he had plenty of
beer guys so Adam as as um there's
clearly a global movement of equality a
gap yeah I'm not here to just you're the
statistic person I don't know
I don't know how large the Gap was 100
years ago to how what the Gap is today
in power forget money let's use the word
power between male and female that used
to be a huge gap the Gap is closing for
sure is there also oh and I'm asking to
you guys is there also maybe something
that's happening subconscious be like
[ __ ] that why why the [ __ ] do they get
to be the ones that date 10 15. this is
our time like we're closing the gap on
everything and in fact we don't even
need you old rich guy I'm gonna make my
own money go get the Young Rich dick or
the young sorry the young broke dick but
it's good dick and he's better looking
than you and I got the money so maybe
maybe there's a piece of the power Gap
closing that that creates um I don't
think you're wrong or or maybe women are
more empowered than ever yeah yeah and
maybe what you find me a 52 year old
money what we're doing with that power
is possibly you know creating healthier
relationships and whoever can bring that
to the table right because we are not no
longer existing because of survival
we're now in a space where we can choose
our mate from a different Criterion
other than their cash because we now
have Financial Independence and
financial balance so you need to bring a
little bit more to the table than than
money you need to right if if you know
unless the the younger guys so not only
sometimes be just moving between older
and younger men in dating what I find in
my small pool is that not only I I don't
know the the physical shape is seems to
be the same in the age groups for me it
seems that these younger men they've
never been married before they haven't
you know dated women you know so closely
so they're not as emotionally damaged
right so they're more open to create you
know a healthy relationship and they'd
probably be an educated a little bit
differently in terms of male and female
relationships so they're just they just
talk and move a little bit different
than than the older guys who think that
you know I can date and marry whoever
you know whenever I feel like it whereas
in these younger guys to me they seem to
be valuing you know family a little bit
more that's what I'm seeing now are you
speaking from experience I'm speaking
from experience okay I've seen that as
well meaning young guys are hollering at
you yeah you're entertaining definitely
sliding
ideas
so if you like that clip click right
here to watch another or if you want to
watch the entire saucecast click right
here
thank you